when did he go into puberty was up to
three years ago what was once you get a
comedy with that two three we're friends
all day you are young I didn't know you
were 23 we we've gone yes
one person real big fan I'm Anna the
fourth dimension has time keep it to
puberty joke somebody yeah okay no I'm I
hadn't very light yeah I uh yeah
probably I was young for migraine but
it's kind of like sophomore high school
I really started to uh hit it all I
remember was the the itch what I
remember having no pubes no no no no no
no fumes don't grow in like a five
o'clock shadow or it's like they all
grow in at once and it's like itchy like
you just shaved right I mean he was
going like one at a time not for old
baby hi we have the age I mean I
distinctly remember I wanted a fresh
shave I watched Total Recall that could
help us fourth dimension this [ __ ] I
watched Total Recall with my friend and
I went to bed that night and I was like
what is happening is there sand dust
paper down there yeah and I was
scratching it in the morning it looked
like a Chia head fully
thing is I didn't experience wet dreams
that much heard about wet dreams I never
really had one but I had a friend who
had two to three a week
oh man would ya and would leave his
fertilized underwear like under his bed
for his mother to fine I don't know how
he got here but that is nasty
that is really horrible that is the big
one John because that's his name I
thought you're gonna say two to three
and night now
that man would be our president yeah
yeah I can't stop just constantly
proving my virility while I sleep yeah
from a distinct part of New York as well